we are we live you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy Network
now this is an American history podcast
where each week I men with eyebrows man
with toes really feeler of soft sheets
Dave Anthony reads a story from American
history to his friend Gareth Reynolds
who has no idea what the topic is going
to be about weird stuff that was great
yeah I know how to do part of I thought
it was really good yeah my PO is good
well especially I didn't brag about
having toes well what happens on this
show is I do our regular intro I get
heaps of judgment and then and then I
toss to you and it's pretty great it's a
pretty great way to start just being
judged hey congrats on him and toes and
eyebrows it's huge some people don't
that's here I don't you tear it well
that's pretty [ __ ] of you so I got a
buddy with two club feet yeah well she
ain't you going around towboats
I don't know if there's no call Matt but
he can kick well I I mean and wouldn't
know what you're being sensitive now no
he's on the Argentinian soccer team
what's his name
note oh yeah a little bit all right what
are we playing the intro we doing dates
or elevate this part over and called it
quote is jam-packed I'm the [ __ ] guy
they look at my name's Gary but it's
good is it for fun and this is not gonna
come particularly quad cast yeah
party officials now hit him with the
puppy you both present sip arguments
about action court no I said my friend
that was great good it's our music yeah
it was good once you stop talking David
I will be at the Denver improv July 26
27 28 I'll be at the Acme comedy club
Minneapolis Minnesota July 30th through
August 3rd I'll be at the Fremont Abbey
in Seattle Washington August 17th and
then comedy state comedy on State
Madison Wisconsin August 22nd through
the 24th 24th two shows recording the
album Garrett Reynolds comm for ticket
info the doll be on tour we'll be in
Irvine in San Diego this August will be
in Madison
oh no be in Sacramento Boise and
September we'll be in Madison in
Milwaukee
in October then we go to Europe we're
gonna be Stockholm Oslo Amsterdam
Glasgow Manchester London Birmingham
Cardiff Dublin and Copenhagen go to doll
podcast.com and get yourself some
tickets them if you want to watch two
men podcast together go to the all
things comedy YouTube page yeah you can
see how dynamic it's really it really
gets when two guys with microphones just
talk it's pretty
watch the it's like a Quentin Tarantino
movie it's like watching the group
theatre mmm-hmm you know them yep this
is great great February 16 1857 year of
our Lord Jesus Congress established the
Columbia Institute for the instruction
of the deaf and dumb and blind in
Washington DC go either way it's not a
it's not a kind name no nope in 1864 the
institution began dispensing college
degrees in comes a college okay Edward a
gala day a gala day I got to look that
up actually to make sure I'm pronouncing
it right because if I'm not I'm gonna
catch so much [ __ ] [ __ ] okay okay
I say it all the time in this now you'll
keep this in there this will be on the
YouTube page so people listening won't
hear this part gala day really terrible
sipping sound celebrate just focus on
what you're doing I'm trying to fund
don't worry what I'm doing it could be
so nice your insides nuttin maybe his
name is gather day or maybe it's
pronounced another way oh no oh no
today's gonna check on his phone alright
mmm-hmm make sure the name he didn't
bone it could be so no gala day he
always putting on the sneaker pimps
Gallaudet yeah okay thank God I checked
that out okay
Gallaudet from the top or wherever
oh we just start we'll just start I'll
just start it we'll just start over
again and I'll edit it February 16th
1857 year Lord Jesus Christ that's
correct and we love it Congress
established the Columbia institution for
the instruction of the deaf and dumb and
blind in Washington DC
okay so hot the hot birthplace of our
Lord
yep you know it yeah you know it yeah
you know it in 1864 the institution
began dispensing college degrees so
their their college dispensing yeah yeah
not just I mean you gotta earn it
right it's like Trump you right Edward
Gallaudet a hearing not deaf man so I'm
using hearing a hearing not deaf man yes
so this story
oh he's a capable of here he's I'll be
using a hearing man or a deaf person
okay
his father Thomas had founded America's
first deaf school so Edward was named
president so he's the first the first
president hearing man later that year
the school's blind students were
transferred to a school for the blighted
Baltimore okay
the college was renamed a Gallaudet
College in 1894 in honor of Thomas
innate in 1910 Edward was replaced by a
hearing man another hearing man
president okay who served us till 1945
he was he was then succeeded by another
hearing president that's quite a run a
hearing then yeah everyone's hearing a
lot of hear a lot of hearing yeah
in the 1960s deaf faculty members spoke
up about the disrespect from an
administration that was still dominated
by hearing people right interesting okay
yeah so like everything else
yep just like everything else yep they
should be in charge I'm [ __ ] out of
here on this one
I can't take it anymore hearing
university president Edward amaryl took
office in 1969 he just their concerns by
forming the President's Council on
deafness good
so he's found a council yeah a group of
deaf faculty who could bring their
concerns of deaf people directly to
Gallaudet's president okay
my guess at all it'll fall on deaf ears
Merrill also appointed many deaf people
to important campus positions okay so
he's sort of here I mean yeah okay in
October at 1983 Merrill retired
Gallaudet was the country's only liberal
arts college for the Deaf but it still
had never had a deaf president weird
right and yes it was kicked off in 1857
sure so quite a run of the hearing you'd
think at this point somebody would be
deaf in charge Gallaudet uh so only a
quarter of its trustees were deaf okay
that's the deck response yeah I mean
what I just don't I would you would just
okay
ya know wouldn't you think you would
just assume that just that would be how
it is yeah
Merrill told the Board of Trustees his
replacement should be deaf great
he's like it is time for a deaf person
be president of this college sure for
deaf people Merrill there was a quote
small but powerful click within the
board composed primarily of members who
viewed deafness from a clinical point of
view or who had a strong corporate
mentality or both we'll call them the
Senate so by clinical point of view that
means deaf people are broken fix them
right okay good
right that's the right opposed they're
just people right as opposed to nuance
with each individual the group
spearheaded the hiring of another
hearing president good so great so I'll
come together
yep he only lasted three months and then
he resigned
okay Jane Spellman a bold move would be
to just be like I'm going to become deaf
oh my god that's how you just how much
really then you're the king I care yes
Jane Spillman the hearing chairwoman of
the board of trustees said in his
statement there were things that
bothered board members and it was a poor
match and that's why he resigned okay an
interim president was chosen hearing
another hearing man okay I mean even in
turn would be great you could just like
then you could just be like oh we have
like wouldn't that be easy to just do an
internal quick yeah you would think deaf
shift then be like I'll back to hearing
but we tried it was really great we'll
do it again Jen even give him that help
Jerry Lee he's the new president after
months his appointment was made
permanent okay students and faculty
became resentful because of the lack of
a formal search one alum quote we felt
misled they probably find it like the
new Dalai Lama it's just like a baby in
the hills and then you fall away which
way did the smoke billows that's right
and then they're like here's the new
that's exactly how they LT president
long as he's not deaf right yes can he
hear yes he's hearing okay great then it
is for sure yeah if he was deaf that
it's the baby next door yeah that's
right
quote we felt miss Spillman pulled a
fast one to get her boy Jerry Lee
selected without really going through
the same through the process okay
the Deaf staffer quote Spillman enjoyed
doing things for deaf people not with
death deaf people you would never dream
of inviting your dog to have dinner with
you
that was her attitude she patted deaf
people on the head oh good god horrible
yeah there you are defi anyway Oh wash
my hand I got some deaf on it totally as
she is I like is 24th 1987 1987 yeah are
we gonna get a black president before
they get a deaf one President Lee
announced he would resign at the end of
the year he'd got a new job at Bassett
furniture sure a natural transition yeah
it was a company owned by the Spillman
family hmm oh okay
boy this is like mini government yeah it
really is
Jane Spellman quote some people might
think the chairman of the board is a
Judas for having the president come to
work for her firm this man is a
businessman and it was very obvious that
he was going somewhere thank God Bassett
was able to attract him I love when
people call out exactly what they did at
the beginning but yeah you know yeah
like some people would say that this is
nepotism this is not nepeta it's like
obviously nepotism and then she
describes nepotism yeah two weeks later
on September 7th the President's Council
on deafness held a meeting 70 or so
people came it was the first time hiring
a deaf president was seriously talked
about in a public forum at the school
the idea rapidly game gained steam among
deaf staff and faculty sure the trustees
form a search committee for the new
president the trustees did yeah five of
the eleven members on the committee were
deaf oh that is so almost barely of
majority so knocking on the door of a
non minority six of the members were
trustees only one was faculty it was
chaired by IBM executive Phillip Bravin
a deaf trustee the committee issued a
press release saying candidates should
have quote a broad and deep knowledge of
deafness sure yeah I mean you guys that
kinda makes well you could just take it
one more step for a little go ahead what
would that you could just be like well
we're after a deaf one oh no no no no
we're just looking for a definite no
because no the person needs to
understand deafness right who better to
empathize with the plight of hearing
impairment than one who is hearing
impaired you too on the nose yeah I
don't know I don't see how that okay
work all right okay okay okay well we
tried we did yes you know that's right
that's right been around for a hundred
years yep right it's all going well yes
okay moving on the committee press
release also said quote
sensitivity to the issues significant to
individuals with disabilities maybe an
accepting alternative one more time
because that's a full of [ __ ]
so they said a deep and broad knowledge
of deafness yeah and sensitivity to the
issue significant to individuals with
disabilities may be an acceptable
alternative sure okay an alternative
great so they're already sort of doesn't
it's gonna be a little bit deaf right oh
and knowing American Sign Language was
preferred preferred interesting so
communication with these students was
preferred could you rather you be able
to communicate with the students but
it's not a must is not a must it's not a
must
could you imagine not knowing it's not a
must it's you know the truth is
sometimes if you just give them a pat on
the head that's as good as just having a
regular conversation a willingness to
learn sign language was all that was
needed that seems that seems crazier
yeah you learn on the job
that seems crazier yeah than even not
knowing I think no it's like this person
just doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah
rather than be like he'll slowly figure
it out in September the National
Association for the Deaf director wrote
a column arguing for a deaf president in
October in an open letter to Spelman the
PCD which is what I said earlier the the
group that you know the President's
Council on deafness okay said maril had
created right right I remember that yes
from earlier on this one yeah on this
podcast right yeah yeah from today's
thing yeah yeah we just talked about in
this one it was there yeah we were in
this one yeah yeah we talked about it on
this episode anyway the PCD alright now
I gotta find it no boy Hampton the P
City asked for a new president of the
College to be deaf so 67 people applied
for the job okay only nine or deaf
interesting not a great start
that's a really bad especially with a
board that seems pretty against the
search committee narrowed it down to 12
people okay and let me goes to death
they got a petition
demanding a deaf president from 200
faculty members Hey
On January 1st 1988 Jerry Lee resigned
the trustees replaced him with a
temporary management team of four
administrators interesting two of whom
are deaf okay an English teacher and a
graduate student and four others started
getting together to discuss the need for
a deaf president the six men started
calling themselves the Ducks because
they hung out so much and we're tight
together and all that [ __ ]
okay what there's a lot of it's not gray
animals it if you gonna say the Ducks
it's cuz you got to put your head under
water for a little while and come up
whether you look there's other pack
animals yeah there's other pack animals
but they're I think they're thinking of
like ducklings in a row how do okay I
could use a lot of punch ups well Ducks
are also rapists well what kind of
knowledge is that what if they're one of
the animals is that come into play I
might well what a core what I'm supposed
to just sit here the whole time
wondering it okay I'm just giving you
some nature truth you're not helping
this episode dolphins too I'm aware of
dolphins lady jerk dolphin dolphin f3
yeah in early February the search was
down to six candidates okay three
hearing three deaf boys this is like a
real American Idol situation at this
point not many students were pushing for
a deaf president
not many okay it was mostly the staff
and faculty that were like really
pushing it okay so the Ducks planned a
rally to change that on March 1st they
sent out a press release but when media
found out it would be peaceful they were
not interested right well the media has
been consistent for the last thirty
years at least some still wrote about it
I like the Washington Post Senator Bob
Dole and Vice President George Bush and
other politicians wrote in support of a
deaf president well I mean if Bob Dole
and George Bush are writing for this
right yeah how are you - that you [ __ ]
that up yeah no they're too progressive
and the reason they were doing that is
because the federal government pays
about 75
of Gallaudet's budget okay so the duck
started holding planning meetings with
undergrads campus groups like the PCD
interviewed six semifinalist so the PCT
is interviewing in their own people at
the same time okay they learn none of
the three herring candidates that the
committee had picked had any experience
with deaf people at all interesting so
there's that's a good sign right no
because because it means that the three
deaf people that they have are just
total [ __ ] Oh another three are the
ones that one of those people is gonna
get put in yeah that's exactly it yeah
so the the PCD only recommended the deaf
candidates i mean imagine the six of us
hanging out oh my god three of them like
literally have no way to could they be
like what you're gonna be president and
be like sorry what do you do I'm a
little confused oh right they're deaf I
did read that in the pamphlet right
anyone money's great it's like sending
me in to run Madagascar well Dave you
know we'd all love for you to go there
what the [ __ ] just happened what are you
doing here sir well you're giving your
tea a stir with a metal spoon and a
metal cup it could it could have gone
better what about just picking up in
like swirling it around well what are
you what are you a sommelier that's not
how you do this you can though the
promises were podcasters yeah no I know
it look I I agree I've I was wrong there
that was the most English thing you've
ever done right now my mother's like why
do I have such a headache coffee he's
doing something somewhere with tea right
so so obviously the like I said the PCD
are like well if the three hearing
candidates don't have any experience to
deaf people
we recommend the deaf people write a
search committee no brainer but the
search committee doesn't give a [ __ ]
right right the faculty said it then
endorsed Elisabeth Zinser
me guess hearing yes yes how'd you know
hey no no I could smell [ __ ] she was
a hearing vice-chancellor at the
University of North Carolina at
Greensboro on if every twenty eight the
search committee submitted their final
three candidates to the Board of
Trustees king Jordan who was the Deaf
Dean of Jordan
yeah that's isn't I know it's a weird
name but that's a weird name to become
president you already a king yeah he's
already a king he's taking them back
step yeah he's taking a back step
yeah you have total authority yeah
you're also Heather's checks yeah
there's also a king of Jordan see really
close to you could probably stroll into
that country and be like hey what's up
I'm King Jordan Jordan I had a table for
two yeah and they're like oh you can run
right this way
so King Jordan was deaf he was the Deaf
Dean of Gallaudet College of Arts and
Sciences okay
also Harvey course on was picked he was
a deaf trustee okay and then Zinser the
only hearing finalist here we go
on Tuesday March 1st the Ducks big
protest happened a thousand protesters
gathered at Gallaudet's football stadium
there were students faculty staff and
members of the local deaf community deaf
president now buttons were distributed
so that's like the slogan they're gone
yeah deaf president now many speeches
were given in support of a deaf
president the group that marched to the
vacant residence of the university's
president and they chanted deaf
president now in sign language and held
up the deaf power sign which is one hand
raised in a fists and the other held
open with the palm over an ear huh so
the rally is a huge success it gets all
the other students like what's going on
right college students yes so now
students want to know why there had
never been the Deaf president okay but
did now they're like why the [ __ ] is
that never happened
and so they start demanding one the
Alumni Association asked all members to
urge a deaf president be hired I think
you're really setting us up to not get a
different they're gonna get that
president with this one ends happily
students pitch tents on the lawn of the
administration building
they tape posters to the walls including
one reading hey Zinser go back to where
you belong
Gallaudet does not need you get lost
it's tough timing for that one but still
the next day there was heavy rain but
protesters took over a street near the
school until DC police made them leave
the next day they took to the streets
again they didn't block traffic but some
hung from traffic lights you know yeah
do what you gotta do yep the trustees
interviewed candidates one final time
King Jordan said quote now that the
search committee has said to deaf
candidates are qualified you have an
obligation to pick one yeah I mean to
you it's two versus one yeah yeah I mean
if you don't now you're being overtly
dickish Wow 100 protesters held a
candlelight vigil outside a trustee
quote it was a small number and the
board's reaction was so that's all the
opposition there is some of us laughed a
little the protesters the reason there
was such a small group of protesters
because they just thought that it's two
to one they have to at a nice point they
had like literally like well happy yeah
so the Board met at the Mayflower Hotel
on Sunday a deaf trustee warned them if
the new president was hearing there
would be quote vigorous vocal and
possibly even violent opposition yeah
but they're all like none of them speak
sign language they're like what did he
just say these croissants are deliver is
if you guys had these little mini things
with Jam in the middle this was the
first time some of the hearing trustees
learned how intense the students and
faculties feelings were what I mean just
the worst it's just so regular yeah it's
normal it's just oh wait what why what
is it worse oh my god that's not a big
fun decision day faculty staff students
local deaf community members and media
gathered at the school gym for the a
p.m. announcement
at 6:00 p.m. ten of the 14 trustees
voted to elect Elizabeth Zinser
president believable why what just
because I mean why why is that
unbelievable
she's a great candidate yeah all three
deaf trustees voted for King Jordan yeah
I want president King yeah
but many hearing trustees thought censor
was quote an academic superstar good god
academic superstar despite the protests
they thought they may be derelict in
their responsibilities if they didn't
choose her unbelievable
Reuben that'd be true is that true what
that do they rely mean is it do they
really think that no right I know okay
all right
Spellman called and offered Zinser the
job and she accepted great good god damn
close it up it's good story right story
that's you know that's awesome all right
um we thank anyone or how do you know I
think we're just happy someone called
the Gallaudet PR office where there
happened to be one of the ducks there
and he heard the news he ran to the gym
and told the crowd but the board had
already taken the awesome step of
leaving out flyers that read quote first
female president oh wow nice nice smooth
Devils
I mean well the guys are out of the
protest equation ladies carry the torch
we no longer made one student said she
quote found the papers all over the
ground the board decided they wouldn't
make the announcement in person but just
left papers it's like I don't want to
get [ __ ] for Todd it's not even talking
showing Trump a lot of people are
depressed the day after Trump got
elected at this one girl I know and
Instagram was like you guys the first
lady was an immigrant everyone was like
get off so
get off I don't want this today so after
the shock wore off the crowd gathered
outside on Florida Avenue and blocked
all six lanes of traffic a few angry
protesters protest leaders spoke someone
asked if anyone knew where the trustees
were meeting good question first
question it was supposed to be a secret
but nobody knew the mayflower so soon
there was a mad dash for the Mayflower
go to the throk to land on them that's
right yeah which was miles away right
and they actually started running in the
wrong direction and a Washington Post
reporter had to tell them to turn around
okay sure
just that like spinal tap rock and roll
yeah
well and I mean you are probably so
fired up oh yeah that you're just like
let's go west west
run in every direction let's go when the
crowd arrived with hotel the trustees
were eating dinner oh yes joy in their
great work Dave my dream yeah the
protestors tried to enter but cops
threatened to arrest them the trustees
eventually invited one of the ducks one
of you may come in student party
president
haibach and another student inside for a
meeting okay Spillman said the decision
was non-negotiable oh just the work yes
she's the worst quote Zinser has a good
attitude just give her time your
feelings will go away in a few days I am
that is that sorry that is [ __ ]
ludicrous no way it's gonna get worse I
can't I understand that you are
emotional but it will be alright and
things will get back to normal
hey let's drink wine from her skull how
about that everybody wouldn't that be
fun too
they went crazy when you have had an
injustice to you and someone says I
understand you're emotional it's
literally the worst thing you're still
patting people on the head yeah she's
totally 1% patting people on that
your emotions what oh my god yeah but
just Oh mm-hmm
more media were called the hotel and
this time they were told the protests
would not be peaceful okay
so there's an angry crowd outside the
finally Spillman goes out to talk to
lady reading the room she praises in
sirs qualifications and implored them to
give her a chance your emotions will go
away you're just angry for no reason the
protestors asked questions she answered
the less difficult ones often with
self-incriminating non answers it did
not help that she said at one point
quote deaf people are not ready to
function in a hearing world Oh what what
she's saying that's her way of saying a
deaf president wouldn't be ready because
it can't communicate with anyone hearing
ya deaf president can't run the school
that's crazy
it's [ __ ] insane it's like so it's
like so 1800s thinking about you know
other people that are white and like
it's [ __ ] crazy it's it's it's well
it's this 1888 it's the same argument
it's the you make the argument both ways
if you want I mean it's like no but I
mean that just makes no sense it's just
saying is that a hearing person can't
communicate with the deaf as well just a
person the kid here right it's [ __ ]
crazy yes right it is crazy but so that
means that there's like a there's a
eugenics part to this in her that's
what's happening so we are definitely
calling her the hero of the podcast
right during the discussion she would
often turn and discuss things with a
hearing trustee who was beside her on
the other side was the deaf trustee and
who she totally ignored the entire time
right yeah says it all this person
doesn't exist right yeah
is it time to feed dogs caviar in front
of hobos a she great to meet some
students the next day in her office but
the crowd wasn't having it so she gave
in and said it could be in the gym and
open to the entire public after that the
crowd dispersed with no arrests how she
slept that night she's [ __ ] lucky she
wasn't hitting head with a rock yeah
honestly yeah
the next day before dawn I'd be so great
if she lost her hearing if that happened
[Laughter]
the next day before dawn students parked
cars in front of five of the school's
entrances and deflated the tires and
then padlocked the gates
okey doke at the 6:00 entrance they
gathered and blocked all traffic classes
were cancelled Spellman had the police
cut a hole in the fence and she crawled
through it cool I mean that's how you
know things are going really well when
cops have to cut a hole through a fence
for you to crawl through and you're in
charge perfect but they were literally
not letting anyone off like King Jordan
Kent couldn't get on campus they turned
him away they're like guys I got ya he's
like no you're not King anymore have you
ever seen the movie taps I'm the king
kiss their yeah no no no you're if
you're it's just that your name is K yes
it okay yeah no Ted's one leg what no
kiss the ring dude you're doing a Dean
eat the ring at a school eat the ring no
turn the chariot around what page around
you literally in a Volkswagen Beetle the
chariot will turn around if someone
could move the garbage can behind it I
don't have a reverse camera it's the de
Diez please let him go
well we're gonna have those Y turns turn
it into a W as you were gentlemen
off we go the worst tires flat butt
so media media went got on to the school
grounds of media on spillin and some
trustees requested a meeting with
protest leaders okay so they went to me
with her and they gave her two
non-negotiable demands a deaf person had
to be made president
okay good start and Spillman had to
resign from the board hey great - top -
great - she's like how can we get this
over and they come over you get the [ __ ]
out so deaf person has to be in charge
and you have to go No okay so I was
talking about how we can get the the
games eligible your justice we soldered
your fence piece back in your apt like
mole there's other things that are
trapped like darts yeah do you want to
trap the animals yes okay how leave
gentlemen I want to talk to her 101
cause that door it's time to trap the
Ducks and moles cinnamon today we trap
the moles and the docs she's reading the
parrot the person ASL translators like
pretty sure how this work are you seeing
moles and ducks so obviously the meeting
didn't go well when they issue their
demand right and it was Spillman saying
since his appointment was final and
quote if you have any questions go ask a
lawyer so then the big Jim meeting
happened oh she's still doing that yeah
she was trying to see if she could nip
it in the bud before she had to do the
Jim meeting right right
so Spillman took the stage and right at
you everybody go get it go doing it go
right alright that's that school spirit
feels like homecoming a water bottle hit
my stomach
so right if she got up on stage a deaf
faculty member who was in the meeting
earlier stepped in front of her nice and
he signed what had happened in the
meeting that protest leaders had refused
to meet their demands to the crowd you
mean yeah right and then he signed quote
should we leave and everyone got up and
started walking out now Spillman didn't
understand what had happened because she
didn't know silence a great advantage
cuz she didn't know sign like a great
event because she didn't know sign
language because the chairman didn't
know sign language because for years she
had been on the board of trustees and
never learned sign language a deaf
person in that she didn't know sign
language right so y'all going well yeah
I wish I'd learned sign let it awkward
yeah could you turn around and say it
somewhat your mouth do the sign to say
stop that is [ __ ] you I know what that
one that was clear that one and their
hands balls are out and that's not even
a sign that is not that it's a different
sign rude different type so she watches
as hundreds of people just walk out the
exits interesting that's an interesting
knowest no one's talking to her no one's
telling her why she's just like hmm so
an organizer quote that was the turning
point of the whole protest that was that
moment was like an assassination right
after that it was at our confusion pure
chaos a few people stayed and got on the
mic they angry Lee questioned and the
lectured Spillman and the trustees one
student asked why a deaf candidate
wasn't selected and Spelman in the
trustees Spillman said the trustees they
used their own judgment and she didn't
know why each voted the way they did
finally she headed the forum quote some
board members have planes to catch and
their schedules are already upset this
woman needs to this what do we do what
did we get I guess poor classes she
needs to have a relatability course I
mean she needs to understand how to
late when you're cornered there are
studies that show that when you become
very rich you essentially become a
psychopath yeah you just lose all touch
with human beings
yeah that's not surprise but she's a
great example that's an incredibly rich
woman right she is arrogant anybody who
is not like her is completely beneath
her yeah and she's a [ __ ] monster
it's like talking being 12 years old and
talking to Diane Feinstein about climate
change that's correct
the protestors gathered at the one open
gate for a march to the Capitol okay
police tried to stop them from leaving
saying that they needed a parade permit
one man told the police he would
translate what they were saying but
instead signed that all the students
should quote make a run for it that's
great what a great advantage I know
right yeah that's I mean I mean this
literally speaks to the issue that
they're kind of a saying about what you
don't understand us yeah exactly
you're not trying to understand yeah and
so if you'd if actually every way if
everyone did give a [ __ ] everyone wants
to learn sign language yeah cool yes and
why wouldn't you so I think would make
seems like something everyone should
learn probably so
so the protesters sprinted through the
gates before the cops knew what was even
happening and to the Capitol and they're
going to get a parade permit so at the
Capitol a leader some people give
speeches and then a leader listed there
now for demands great deaf president now
end Spellman's reign a deaf majority
board of trustees and forget about
reprisal reprisals against the
protesters right mm-hmm and we get to
eat Spillman yes cooked cooked obviously
we're not savages
give us cooks build the next day classes
were still canceled because they were
still blocking everybody a huge rally
was held on campus protesters burned
effigies of Spillman and Zinser so if
you're Zinser are you like what
my stuff in this what's the idea cuz I
saw there's a little hole in the fence
but I'd say that everything's pretty
shut off she's not even there yet how
did they take it on the phone what did
the students think were they excited
hello hello hello birding what hello
well now she found out because news
coverage went national TV stations
around the country interviewed deaf
people which gave the deaf community a
previously unheard of visibility and
raised national awareness of the issues
just how Spillman drew it up right
perfect before dawn Wednesday students
again blocked the gates with cars and
lock them shut classes are canceled
again and then Zinser got a little cocky
oh dear she was supposed to start in
July what don't show up early but she
called Spellman and asked if she could
be appointed immediately oh my god
sins are quote you had a team of four
administrators to run the university and
committees don't run the universities
effectively in a crisis yeah and I am
crisis Sally yeah exactly get involved
perfect bad morning this will help this
will help this is what this is what is
needed is for her to immediately take a
right he's not gonna calm everything I
don't want you there in July come there
now everything's better that's right
right and by the way this is showing the
instincts of a great leader just a great
hunter problem assessor problem solver
exactly if thank you yeah so Spillman
agreed great so they're both really good
at this yeah they're out of their
[ __ ] mind right so now sins arrived
in DC to hold her afternoon into direct
into her introductory press conference
okay the four main student organization
organized errs met with King Jordan who
seemed unsure of what to do then they
met with Zinser she asked them to set
aside their demands for a few days after
which she would work with them to try to
code quote find a common agenda yeah
well that's right once yeah a common
agenda we can work together on this yeah
this thing where you don't want me here
we can work on that I can figure out a
way to
be deaf give me a chance I need three
days let me just set up my stuff but she
said the students were quote out of
control unwilling unable to even think
about it yeah her feelings
yeah her feelings I mean she she's
looking for a compromise supposed to
make a lot of money this is pretty real
the meeting lasted ten minutes okay one
of the students quote at first Zinser
was a very nice woman and sensitive but
she did not listen I felt she should
have talked with us more if she really
wanted to hear our position Spillman
started the press conference to
introduce in sir at 2:00 p.m. what we're
like the height in a jar I think that's
facility yeah it's probably the hotel or
something yeah you know it's definitely
not on camp okay right a reporter asked
why a school should be run by someone
who couldn't speak the language of its
student body yeah you know there's a
university in France where they're sick
of the Spanish president it's like yes
it's so [ __ ] crazy
Spillman then said Zinser was learning
sign language okay okay well put your
[ __ ] money where your mouth is let's
see
and then Spellman said she had never
learned sign language because she was
quote too involved in very boring but
vital matters such as making
presentations to Congress and raising
funds to have much interaction with deaf
people I was too busy to be an empath so
she's literally saying she was busy
doing boring stuff she couldn't learn
their stupid little language that's
right yeah so she doesn't have time to
interact with - - for Congress okay she
had for the Concord you ever know how
important that job is and then sends her
spoke she talked about the enormous and
exciting challenges she expected at
Gallaudet well I've got good news for
her some very exciting challenges have
been thrown her way and that she had
indeed started learning sign language
listening a reporter asked if she would
resign if after hearing more from
students
she felt she was quote the problem
Zinser said she'd only resign if the
Board of Trustees asked her to well okay
King Jordan spoke and said as the
Gallaudet teen Dean he had to support
the Board's decision then he added quote
Gallaudet will never be the same the
deaf world has changed and has been a
very positive change
Spillman said Zinser was already
officially Gallaudet president retro
actively dating it - three days earlier
okay
someone sarcastically asked Zinser if
she'd be leaving in a few years to go
work for Bassitt furniture that's pretty
maybe they have a lot of money I love
money what kind of food money's great
money's better than any of the problems
Jordan was asked if he thought the
protests should stop he said quote yes I
do interesting yeah the skin can just
make it so well the students were very
upset by King Jordan's remarks he said
he said that and then he walked off the
stage and there was a student there he
was close to and she just shook her head
and couldn't look him in the eye do you
think that would you don't look good I
crushed the soul of that girl uh-huh
would you see that she fell to her knees
so the four student leaders vowed campus
protests would continue until demands
were met even if this meant giving up
their Spring Break that was starting
that weekend oh you know to the fact
that the oh the trustees are counting on
that oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah their
University faculty voted 147 to 5 for a
resolution calling for his injuries
resignation interesting who would the
[ __ ] 5 yes 5 and a her 136 to 11 for
resolution advocating the other three
protest demands great
sounds like a majority although some
said they felt pressured to not support
Zinser at all yeah imagine that night a
student leaders Ensor an actress Marlee
Matlin appeared on Nightline with Ted
Koppel I did Marlee Matlin's kids
birthday parties right I finally yeren
have a dog in this you're finally you're
finally in a dollop I'm finally yeah
this is kind of meta yeah this is nuts
am I gonna cover this you are does this
go all the way to when I do at kids
birthday yeah that's the end this is
exciting
when Zinser said she'd stay in office
unless the trustees asked her to step
down Ted Koppel called her quote a
puppet you're a puppet and said she
could resign if she wanted to yeah which
is it's a perfect like little ironclad
argument because you're like well if the
trustees asked me to like tell me I have
to go I'll go the trustees are the
majority of them want you in there yeah
and they would be like well if she wants
to leave she can resign that's right
Matlin accused Ensor of arrogance for
taking over a deaf school without
knowing much about deaf people the show
ended with everyone trying to basically
yelling at each other all at once Kapil
call that quote something approaching
anarchy right and CNN called it
something that we will make our network
but but not so because CNN never calls
someone what they are like Ted Koppel
call up a puppet fair so fair outside of
that yeah really
Thursday morning cars have been towed to
clear two entrances so students
hot-wired school buses drove them in
front of the gate it's worse by hand
they're bigger and deflated the tires
okay
worse good work everyone they also put
up Tunes tombstones for Zinser and
Spillman that's good nice nice touch
clear def and even some hearing students
around the country we're rallying at
their own schools and support and some
were like driving down in bus loads to
help protest it's becoming a bigger
movement for the deaf community
students threatened to seize the
president's campus house and office
if Zinser made her way past students
blocking entrances to the school okay
the doors to the administration building
were chained shut so no and no
administrators are on campus at one
point words ends are their words in Zuri
would sneak on campus and they started
checking chunks of cars going by so if
you're hurry you're like I can't go
today that's like [ __ ] Red Dawn yeah
there was even a rumor she would be
flown in by helicopter that would land
on this she's parachuting in I don't
have you guys heard this
she's parachuting in got a jet pack
she's digging her way through she's
tunneling I mean she's gonna El Chapo
her way in if she tunneled her way and
this would be the greatest tunnels away
and I think at some point you gotta go
all right all right you're president
president you did you've shown you've
won the month yeah I rallied that
afternoon King Jordan surprised everyone
by speaking he signed that while he had
said the day before that he recognized
the board's legal authority to choose a
president quote my personal reaction to
the Board's decision was and is anger at
the continuing lack of confidence that
they have shown in deaf people he then
said he supported the four demands and
quote the efforts to achieve them he
talked to a reporter and and after and
said he had made a mistake the day
before when he said the protest should
stop he saw it now as a civil rights
movement okay he basically thought at
that point he would never be president
he was giving up his career right still
it's good yeah yeah that night ginger
enjoyed a nice dinner with the trustees
and administrators it's just always like
this you don't even need to say that
they're having dinner but you just know
that they're in there more gravy yeah
they're always just eating gravy and
that's how this works
yeah Darvin they try to not get gout
that's right so well the talk of the
table was of the civil rights movement
they were
and this is the first time Zinser had
heard it framed that way
she was already coming around to the
idea that this was a totally unworkable
situation for it quote that was a
turning point in recognizing it as a
largest social phenomenon that's crazy I
mean talk about it you definitely are
not supposed to be there yeah
but they have the fact that you're like
oh this is the civil rights movement
what did you think of well that's what I
mean that's why it looks like you cannot
be there right you don't on your you
don't have the depth she literally
doesn't understand that it's no
different than a white person saying
they should run a black college right
like and then refusing to leave yeah
yeah yeah yeah with gravy and cake with
gravy
I mean we're assuming there's great
there's a lot of gravy there's no is not
great they're eating gravy off the couch
oh there's just gravy
just they probably sat in a big novelty
gravy boat while they dipped like you
know pies in the gravy that surrounded
them that's right my understanding is
they would pour gravy on Spillman and
lick it off of her oh yes what's the
sign for it Thanks so quote I looked at
James Spellman very calmly and said Jane
I resign
well Zinser then told them she wanted to
eat a salad by herself
oh he's cut from the ivory tower to a
boot that Wendy's alone you want a
problem-solver it had been 97 hours one
good run since you voted you have to
it's the deal so at this point did they
just let a little smoke billow out of
the chimney right now a deaf Gallaudet a
faculty member later claims Ensor had a
secret victory parter two weeks before
the vote and a Gallaudet alum set a
hearing trustee congratulated him on his
appointment in late February
so ministers could just be Roux but
rumor
mm-hmm yeah wouldn't surprise me yes the
press was told about her resignation at
11 p.m.
students gathered at the gym and
celebrated in to the morning great
the next morning Zinser and Spellman
held a press conference Zinser said she
was quote deeply disappointed but she
now realized the best way to restore
order was to resign
she finished by saying she was
celebrating the Deaf community's quote
day in the Sun and then signed I love
you alright I'll attend so she had she
had a momentary lack of understanding it
and she came around great had a salad
great it wasn't great that she came but
in the end yep good yep
then Spillman spoke she called Zinj
resignation quote a tragic loss for
Gallaudet and an inevitable step forward
for another institution ready for the
next sentence that will redeem
everything she's said so far no that's
it that's the quote how is it truly that
I would like to say I've learned nothing
and [ __ ] you the deficit yeah is the one
who can hear mm-hmm a hundred percent I
mean there's being deaf and then there's
not being able to list how could you
even be at the same event as what was
her name sends her Zinser see that yeah
revelation and not and not be affected
she probably had no idea that she signed
I love you right she was probably way to
give it to him
screw um I agree sister what'd you just
say kick rocks so there's also you know
and then we see this many times in
history and certainly now where people
know that they're in the wrong and
they've taken a position but the real
problem is is that the less earth ends
are the ones who have shown them that
they're on the wrong right so they can
they cannot [ __ ] accept that so
they'll go to their death rather than
say those people are right
[Music]
she said the Board of Trustee if the
board would meet Sunday to discuss a new
selection process and it was up to the
board whether a deaf president would be
chosen just say you're gonna pick a
goddamn deaf person a reporter asked
Bowman if she knew sign language she
said although she had been on the board
for eight years and the Chairman from
six she had never learned the language
quote this job is extremely demanding
and terribly time-consuming in my
opinion my efforts are best directed in
other areas toward budgets figures and
programs that are not nearly as
pleasurable as learning sign language
well she's got to devote a lot of time
to waste things finding out who the next
president okay well you just had 97
hours she could have used it so does not
take that much time you're down to learn
another language particularly when
you're working with those people you
also know that you really don't care if
you don't even bother to go like I'm
learning it yeah like you're like so
like now I'm not gonna know now I'm
still unchanged unfazed the protestors
held their own press conference leaders
said they would keep the campus closed
until their three and a half remaining
demands were met right they then led a
march of several thousand people to the
Capitol this time they had a parade for
a hermit protest leaders wrote the board
and encouraged them to pick one of the
two deaf finalists instead of starting
over again with a new search yep Zinser
got on a plane and went back to her
position as Chancellor at UNC Greensboro
she was greeted at the airport by
hundreds of supporters with banners and
balloons okay the trustees met Sunday
afterwards Spillman resigned of her own
record despite continued support from
many trustees she said quote a deaf
president deserves a deaf chairman so
now she's just being she got she got
fired I mean come on she got [ __ ]
fired
there's no way after everything she's
done that they weren't like he gotta go
right because this was her [ __ ] this
up left and right the board didn't voted
unanimously to make King and Jordan
president finally the King has his
throne kiss head
effective immediately kiss it I am now
the king president I am now the King
King King president president president
Jordan Jordan Jordan
Spillman and the selection committee
chair held the press conference
announcing Jordans appointment and her
resignation they said there'd be no
punishment for any protest participants
and announced the creation of a task
force to figure out how to make the
board majority deaf the chair said he'd
spoken to student leaders who agreed
they would let the campus return to
normal immediately so they won great the
victorious protesters chug beer and
chanted deaf president Wow great Jordan
gave a press conference signing deaf
people quote have overcome our
reluctance to stand up for our rights
the world has watched the deaf community
come of age we will no longer accept
limits on what we can achieve the crowd
chanted King King King and then Jordan
said he was going home to sleep yeah
sure yeah yeah
in 2006 King Jordan announced he would
retire as Gallaudet president the next
year the trustees were then majority
deaf as per official bylaw they voted to
replace Jordan with a deeply unpopular
deaf Gallaudet provost Jane Fernandes
protests broke out the NAD supported
Amma tensity formed once again students
shut down the school on October 13th
police were arrested 133 protestors for
blocking entrances to the school King
Jordan approved of the arrests the four
deaf president now student leaders from
back in the day released a statement
saying the arrest quote tainted the
spirit of the Deaf president now
movement and reversed king Jordan's
legacy they decried Fernandez as quote
arrogant vindictive autocratic and a
retaliatory style of leadership and
urged her to follow Zins example quote
dr. Zinser considers her resignation the
best thing she has ever done we can only
hope it some day we will be able to
think we were able to thank you for
being courageous enough to take the same
action Fernandez released a statement
she refused to step down because quote
we live in a country that is governed by
the rule of law not anarchy
but that's not an icky that's democracy
yeah lose that all the time they forget
that all the time on purpose deaf
communities throughout the u.s. and
Canada form tent cities of their own in
solidary in October 21st thousands of
deaf people from around the world
marched on the US Capitol on October
29th the Board of Trustees terminated
Fernandes contract nice this is what hey
everybody this is what we need to do
yeah Jordan wrote an op-ed in the
Washington Post denouncing the
protesters insane quote I am convinced
that the board made a serious error in
ascending to the demands of the
protesters by terminating Fernandes
presidency before it began the students
get to have a [ __ ] say he's writing
to college and if they don't [ __ ]
like it every right we always hated our
[ __ ] Chancellor's at UC schools they
were [ __ ] [ __ ] and they [ __ ] us
left and right we should have a [ __ ]
say in who the [ __ ] they are the board
voted to replace Jordan with a deaf
Gallaudet graduate Robert davia on an
interim basis in 2009 he was succeeded
succeeded succeeded by a former nad
president Alan Hurwitz Hurwitz retired
in 2015 and the presidency went to deaf
attorney Robert Kedah no she Roberta can
da know she is Gallaudet second female
president the first was Elizabeth's in
Zaire Wow the Deaf president now
movement is now known just as DPN the
power demonstrated by the Gallaudet
students fuelled efforts around deaf
rights for years to come and also helped
catalyze efforts to pass the American
with Disabilities Act so it like they it
just didn't like Spillman started a
monster like it was most things sleeping
yeah yeah it just kept going and and
you're right it is such a microcosm I
mean it's just like yeah that's it yeah
that's what we live in now yeah I mean
if you want to solve climate change
that's how we have to do it yeah well
and I think even the difference between
88 and 2006 is noticeable too I think
that is a parallel as well is that like
they don't they now know that they can
nor us more than they thought and so
they hyper ignore us so it is going to
take math yeah it's going to take like
being okay with getting arrested and
really yeah really just being okay with
like being like we're shutting the
street down yeah yeah that's right
people pity the deaf people it's always
so funny to people who are like if you
block things then you will just upset
people right so the point of blocking
thing is to tell people that nothing's
gonna be the same until we actually get
our way because that's justice and
what's the alternative
I mean there's no alternative the
alternative is to just be like oh you're
right
nobody happy well we just melt just do
it that way yeah if you don't believe
that you should go talk to Gandhi Martin
Luther King who they killed yes yes a
lot of people yeah yeah hope you're
happy
we signed science we signed science
there's the three ladies by the way oh
wow
that's obviously Spellman yes ugly mean
yes nurse ratchet looking rain finish
right nurse ratchet yep yep all right we
sign the cups thank you
baseball cups sure whatever